[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages so time to see them what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pepper creera and harry cole great to
see both of you staying with us until
just before midnight
so to the front pages then let's start
with the metro which describes today's
bizarre speech by the prime minister two
business leaders as a peppa pig's ear in
light of the references he made to the
children's tv character
the guardian understands a number of
conservative mps are losing confidence
in boris johnson
while the delhi star dubs it the pm's
oddest speech yet
according to the telegraph the brexit
minister lord frost believes the
government must cut taxes or else run
the risk that leaving the eu could fail
the eye carries new government advice to
get a covered test before going
christmas shopping
the financial times leads with joe
biden's decision to renominate jerome
powell to lead the u.s central bank the
federal reserve a controversial decision
as powell was originally chosen by
donald trump
and the son criticizes the decision by
the brit awards to drop specific male
and female categories and go gender
neutral
so let's bring in pipa carrera and harry
cole welcome to both of you um what did
we learn about peppa pig today i suppose
the question leading a number of the
newspapers harry
yes
bizarrely this isn't the first day that
peppa pig has massively derailed british
politics i'm old enough to remember 2010
and the 2010 general election campaign
peppa pig was meant to meet gordon brown
and the uh the tories complained it was
too political
and peppa pig should stay out of
politics
and now today we have this bizarre
spectacle the prime minister who it
turns out had taken his young son two
peppa pig well over the weekend
photographed one point sitting in a tea
cup as far as i can tell um
had uh he tried to he was using his
usual sort of johnson um tactics in
quite a dry speech about business and
taxation trying to butter up um
businesses but telling this great story
about how the world should be a little
bit more like peppa pig and he slightly
botched it he's not exactly firing on
all cylinders at the moment um people
suggest he's been laboring with the uh
the sort of dreaded lurgy that's been
doing the rounds the cold the cold
that's not covered that he can't seem to
shake and i think if he had if he'd been
on normal form for the last you know
couple of weeks and hadn't been bogged
down in sleaze uh allegations in social
care there's a half cocked um trains
announcement last week i think he
probably would have got away with it but
it felt to me it's a sort of physical
embodiment of all the sort of
government's midterm blues all sort of
rammed into one slightly bizarre speech
um but he's been out about tonight um at
various dinners and
my spies tell me he's been doubling down
on his claim that we should all be a
little bit a little bit more like peppa
pig world where everyone's happy and the
uh and the tiny trains run on time it
was um
it was a strange day a strange day i
mean you know some might say i know he's
had a holiday and that was controversial
um but it's been a busy time hasn't it
for a prime minister who does have a a
young child a baby on the way brain fog
with said cold i can sympathize with
that i have to say um you know everybody
runs out of steam eventually at this
time of year is that is that excusable
or losing your place or your page or
whatever it was in the speech today with
the multiple forgive me um that's all
quite naturally done isn't it
i think it's about prioritizing those
isn't it and i think the prime minister
who's had actually quite a testy
relationship with big business for a
conservative to turn up at the cbi
conference and make an in-person speech
to them
um
and
array of
business luminaries in the audience
who were sitting there waiting to see
whether he was going to try and build
bridges with them
uh not just because some of his previous
comments about how he regards business
but also
into the post-brexit world and to
come up with a speech which it was
really not very serious
littered with the normal johnson
metaphors but they didn't land this time
um i think really a lot of business
people that we spoke to up there after
the speech felt that it just wasn't
serious and actually it's a bit
disrespectful um of of business it
didn't land well with them it also
didn't land well with conservative mps
you showed the guardian front page there
but every paper has been covering it
sort of the rumblings we've had from the
backbenchers
about how this speech um really just
looked so shambolic um it was the latest
in a series of um bad front pages for
the prime minister in recent weeks we've
had the obviously the tourist sleeves
right which he kicked off with his his
mishandling of the owen patterson affair
swiftly followed by last week's um rise
over rail and whether investment in the
north had been all the
infrastructure the north had been
oversold and they were under delivering
and then obviously tonight where um as
we talked the mps had just voted on
social care plans which many of his own
backbenchers feel as downgrading it
promises um it kind of feels like number
10 isn't handling things very well at
the moment uh we've had a lot we'll see
a lot of that in all the papers tomorrow
um ultimately the buck stops with the
prime minister and maybe he should
prioritize that cbi speech and not try
to rush around to all these other events
tonight um she can handle donors and so
on yes i mean i suppose politics needs
money doesn't it if that's an excuse for
that
but the question is if you look at that
guardian
can you stop the rot effectively can you
draw a halt to this and does he need
some more grown-ups with him in downey
street is he missing the likes of edward
lister the suggestion always was that he
would be you know the chairman to the
chief executive or whatever that role
would be where you know he's going to be
nurtured by people does he need some
extras in there harry
yeah i think we are in slightly i mean
it was a
he's having a bad week he's have about
about a couple weeks he's about had a
bad day i do think there is a slight
problem though of people and the same
old people who always always hated this
prime minister even before his prime
minister
um slightly suffering from sort of
forest arrangement syndrome who are now
saying you know oh my god here's our
chance finally the whole world is gonna
come around to our way of thinking and
we're going to jump up and down and say
we told you so the guy's a clown look
weren't we proved right and i just think
you know level-headed level heads are
needed a little bit there is clearly
some problems within within number 10
number 11
uh the wider cabinet feel that they're
not being listened to their advice is it
sort of falls at the wayside there's
some rather unedifying scrapping tonight
between
um we've sort of got right into the
criminology of what is a downing street
source is it someone from number 10 or
is it someone from number 11 there's
some
barbs being traded uh about the cabinet
needing to step in to do more with the
prime minister however i would just step
back and think actually
you know six weeks ago people were
saying he's gonna rule for seven years
you know he's he's not going anywhere
he's at the top of his game and you're
just saying in the ebb and flow of
politics the
you know don't be too quick to you know
to base on on the back of one week this
idea that the this prime minister
doesn't have a a connection to two
voters in a way that the tory party have
not had for a very long time and you
know take the guardian there the
headline i'd argue is a little
overwritten um they've got they've
managed to find three anonymous back
bench tour mps you don't like boris
johnson and frankly give me five minutes
i'll get them on the show if you want
yeah i mean it is the guardian on a tory
of course isn't it um but let's go to
your paper front page of the the mirror
as you suggested uh in the last uh half
hour or so the vote on social care and
you you know it's it's really not
surprising why governments don't tackle
social care you know it's burnt a few
hasn't it along the way pippa
yes and we've had successive governments
making promises that haven't then
uh been delivered and you know my
personal view is that this government
deserves some credit for at least
putting the issue on the table however
that doesn't mean you can gloss over the
detail of how it's been handled and
what's what's on offer and so andrew
dilnuts who of course was the architect
of the original social care plans that's
got so far with david cameron but not
actually into legislation suggested that
what is now being suggested by the
government while better than the
situation now and i think it's right
that we that we um that we note that is
not as good as um as what was promised
by the prime minister and this is a bit
of a pattern really with boris johnson
is that this feeling that he over
promises none of delivers you know he
could have actually had a great success
with some of his real announcements last
week had he not promised so much and
tied it all up to this leveling up
agenda um that he that he was sort of a
core pledge at the
2019 election this week again i mean the
changes are quite dramatic it's the
first time they've had a cap on care
costs um right but instead because he's
promised that nobody's ever gonna have
to sell their house and because he
suggested that um you know that poorer
homeowners were going to be better
supported than actually it actually
turns out that they will be um and
because inevitably because of the price
of properties lots of those people that
have been west affected by the changes
in the cap are in the north of england
it looks like he's actually under
delivering again so you know it's as
much a problem with the messaging and
the handling of how they sell their
policies not just their
adventures but also the public
um as it is about the policies
themselves and you know it's not just
one day of bad headlines it's several
weeks and it's starting to have an
impact in the polls where i agree with
harry is that you know that in itself
does not bring down a government and
boris johnson is a very long way from um
you know being ousted by his story about
benches for example i mean some chatter
about that but i don't think anyone
really takes that seriously
uh you know he is a politician that has
an incredible ability to to bounce back
he's done it before um but it just does
feel now that he's in a position not
only where um you know he's got all
these problems many of which are of his
own making we lurch from one to the next
to the next but also the labour party
has started to capitalize on them one of
the criticisms of them
okay sorry to rush you um i did want to
find out who the uh the most popular
tory was in terms of the bidding uh your
front page champagne drinking toys rush
back from millionaire donors party
devoted in favor of making poorer
pensioners pay more for social care top
billing was what harry very quickly
with an hour
an hour of cricket with rishi sunak for
35 000 quid or a more a bargain night
out of karaoke with liz truss for 22
000. i'm getting live updates at the
auction it's happening now well you can
keep us posted as the evening progresses
plenty more still to come in the next
part of our programme at the very latest
on the brit awards dropping male and
female categories to go gender-neutral
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now pippa and
harry cole from the mirror and the sun
peppa let's go to the daily telegraph
now shall we and this is uh lord frost
he of brexit fame obviously suggesting
that with bricks it must come other
things like cutting taxes so we don't
follow the european model
yeah it's interesting isn't it on the
day that the prime minister gave his big
speech to business it's actually it's
actually lord frost that makes the front
page of the telegraph
the story sort of in in-house paper as
it were
and it's interesting that he felt bold
enough or feels bold enough to speak out
on government policy like tax when
really this is the remit of the
chancellor or the prime minister he was
of course one of the few cabinet
ministers that spoke out in cabinet
um against national insurance rises that
were announced recently
his warning is that brexit might fail if
the government doesn't um
decide to cut taxes and reduce
regulations for business that business
isn't just a cash cow um
in order to support the public sector
and he's warning of course not to
unsurprisingly probably to not to follow
the european social model though it is
worth noting that um there are countries
with a higher tax take than the uk which
also have higher gdp per capita a long
list of them including germany and you
know belgium the netherlands finland
austria could go on so it's not as
simple as saying that there's one
european social model that that fits all
and a quick look at the front of the sun
harry your paper uh which pits two of
the uk's biggest stars head to head um
because the brits have gone
gender-neutral
yeah another one of these classic ones
of uh
of walkery that um people get very angry
about um but actually i think we'll
probably end up backfiring because at
the moment there are separate categories
of men and women at the brit awards
now in pitting artists male and female
artists against each other statistically
speaking
fewer women artists are going to get are
going to get awards so it feels like a
one of those great things that's step
dressed up as a great forward step in
progress and actually in reality is but
a bit of a step backwards for
uh
in a lot of ways so i imagine it's a
talker and i wonder how long before we
hear from
new culture secretary on this one we
were trying to coax her into saying
something about it earlier but i don't
suppose it'd be long you'll have to keep
trying won't you harry pippa thank you
very much indeed